les règles du freestyle 80 secondes et 7
sauts spectaculaires pour convaincre
cinq juges seront pris en compte la
variété la technique l'originalité
l'amplitude des sceaux et la réactivité
du public les figures se nomme ta carole
black flip ou d'abord gras bindi et sont
servis par l'appel est international de
très haut niveau parmi eux un français
champion du monde 2013 deuxième au
classement actuel david rinaldo je
pourrais passer toute ma vie sur la moto
je suis plus à l'aise sur la moto qui
sont mes pieds donc ça reste vraiment
premièrement déjà roulé en moto et après
si on peut avoir le spectacle et les
gens qui sont autour c'est juste énorme
une étape surprise pour le public
tourangeau cette nuit de l'extrême est
l'aboutissement d'un long travail en
amont c'est compliqué surtout de faire
venir cette manche de championnat du
monde en france est effectivement
aujourd'hui le challenge après huit ans
c'était de pouvoir être la ville qui
pouvait accueillir ces championnats du
monde freestyle et le challenge était
que le public réponde cette quatrième
étape du championnat du monde a été
remportée hier soir par david rinaldo
devant l'espagnol tenant du titre mais
l'hérault et le japonais higashino